Rob when the when the season ended
LeBron had just kind of sat in front of
all of us and molded about his
basketball mortality in a way that I
don't think any of us had ever heard him
uh um being around him this Summer and
speaking to him in what ways did you
kind of see the fire relit and I I
assume you've seen it um I don't know
have you seen his does he seem refreshed
in any in any
ways I would answer that with one word
preparation um you know just it's it's
it's staggering for a player that um has
years you know under the hood already
and is preparing for 21 like he's a
rookie um I think he's been doing you
know six a.m
workouts probably been in our building
as much as any player this off season um
been in the weight room as much as any
player um I think every team LeBron's
played for it's pretty uniform that um
his work sets the tone and there has
been nothing but an increase in in
seeing that here so to me it's it's
let's be about it let's not talk about
it and he's definitely been about it
this offseason and I think that that
really
puts kind of the spirit in our entire
group to see him preparing that detailed
and working that hard